>> With a tattoo of his mother.
Sara sidner, thank you so much
for being with us.
Keep us posted.
>>> Now Antonio Romanucci.
He is one of the attorneys
representing Tyre Nichols's
family.
Thank you so much for being with
us.
I'm sorry it is under these
circumstances.
How is Mr. Nichols' family doing
now that the officers have been
indicted?
>> Well, clearly, they wanted
the utmost absolute charges.
And I think with what we see
today, they're going get that.
John, I don't know the last
time, if ever, I've seen a
uniformed police officer under
the color of law being charged
with kidnapping.
We have to take that in and
really soak that for a moment
and understand the gravity of
what happened here to tyre.
>> Why does that have particular
gravity to you, the kidnapping
charge?
>> Well, you know, look, I've
been thinking of all different
ways to describe what happened
on that video since it hasn't
been released yet.
And here is another way for me
to describe it, which may give
you some context.
It was an mma fight, except
there was only one side that was
mma.
You know, tyre was helpless.
He was defenseless.
He was restrained.
And that's why you're seeing the
types of charges that you're
seeing here from second-degree
murder to obstruction to
aggravated assault to
kidnapping, because he was
literally, his freedom was taken
away from him because he didn't
do anything wrong.
The proportionality of what
happened here was so askew that
it only warranted the highest
level of charges.
>> You just said it was like a
one-sided mma fight.
You also describe it as Mr.
Nichols being treated like a
human pinata.
Those were your words.
Do you think Memphis, the
community there, is prepared to
see this video, which you have
seen?
>> They're going to have to be
prepared, John.
I think one way to prepare them
is for us to be able to describe
it so hopefully when they do see
it, especially along with the
charges, that there is peace.
That is the goal.
Should their voices be heard?
Absolutely.
There is no doubt about that.
But there should be anything but
peace in the streets?
Correct.
That's what we're looking for.
>> What do you know about the
traffic stop that took place
that led up to this?
Do you even know why he was
stopped?
>> No, we really don't.
And that's not anything that I'm
saying that's been withheld from
us.
But we don't know yet.
We know that the police have
said that this was a traffic
stop.
But we don't know more than
that.
And quite frankly, I have to
tell you, right now, I don't
know that it's a justification
that they're saying it was
traffic stop.
Because we know that the
saturation and suppression units
do use a pretext to stop in
order to carry out this wolf
gang-like mentality, this
wolfpack mentality of policing.
>> You have no specific
knowledge that that's what
happened here.
You're suggesting, though, it's
a possibility?
>> It's only a possibility,
that's correct.
>> I understand the preliminary
results of an autopsy
commissioned by you and attorney
Ben crump and the family, those
results are in.
What do you know at this point
about those results?
>> So here's what I can tell you
about those results.
The results indicate that what
we saw in the video are
consistent with the a severe
beating.
And our independent medical
examiner has authorized us to
quote that.
The injuries are consistent with
a severe beating.
Meaning that the hemorrhage that
was found was so deep that it
could only be caused by blunt
force trauma, which again is
consistent with a severe
beating.
>> I know you've got a lot on
your plate, as does the family.
But lastly, does the family at
this point intend to sue the
city of Memphis?
>> Well, I think a lawsuit is
clearly on the horizon.
I'm not going to tell you when
that's going happen.
We have to complete our
investigation.
And I'm hoping that the
productive meeting that we had
with the FBI, the doj, and the
Shelby county state's attorney,
that we've all committed to
ourselves that we're going to
cooperate with each other that
that continues.